en brut je me sens très stressée et une
fois que j'aurai coller mais faisons que
ça ira beaucoup mieux tout se joue sur
des bombes non je suis surexcitée parce
que on va voir un film que j'attends
depuis depuis longtemps ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle et
je pense que tous les fans de la belle
base comme si je connaissais le
bannerman se sont excités de cette
sortie et apparemment c'est une très
grosse montée des marches il ya tout
tout le crew du film qui vient donc
c'est trop cool j'aimerais vous dire
qu'on s'y habitue dont s'était tue pas
c'est mon deuxième vrai festival de
cannes et je m'y habitue pas pas
toujours aussi regagné 7 choix
ça c'est ya pa pou l'ena situation que
ce que ge en train de faire